[Music]
when I was 20 I stopped talking for like
three months I didn't know what was
wrong it was dark the only time I used
my voice was that night I would walk by
myself and I would sing I never sang
before then I needed to listen to the
voice inside of me to find out what my
purpose was and I decided I remember I
was like I'm gonna be a singer I'm Liz
oh I am a rapper I'm a singer I'm a
songwriter and I live in Los Angeles
California once I decided to become a
finger my mission became very clear to
me my music is activism because my mere
existence as a musician is activism and
I want you to use the song to activate
you to make the world a better place
real well big-girl knees with credo see
black women you don't see big girls like
me and that should change I want to see
tons of plus-size pop stars I want to
see black girl magic I just want to see
us way more imagine a heaven where all
of the angels and goddesses are thick
and voluptuous and just scrumptious
no dude I'm queen growing up in Detroit
I was raised very very very strict
Pentecostal couldn't go to movies
couldn't listen to secular music it was
the devil when you're finding your voice
you can't have any restrictions on
yourself you can't have any fears so I
had to let go of all of that to find my
voice and see a little ratchet but my
family still loves her
ooh one more I'll let you go okay I'm
gonna tie myself up I wouldn't be here
if I didn't stop talking for three
months I wouldn't be here if I didn't
tell myself to be a singer everything
else actually just started falling into
place
that's what finding your purpose is all
about the universe conspires with you
[Music]
[Music]
we are mix trade we are black and white
we are French and Cuban and we'll have
this African culture when your mom is on
told you
[Music]
we really feel like all of that is what
makes us
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
my name is Danny beers I am Melissa kind
I and we are eBay eBay means twins in
Yoruba and we're twenties I did the
piano parts and melody the lyrics I do
all the duction and rhythm basically I
did a skeleton and she gives it the
flesh and the skin
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we grew up listening to French artist
and old soul singers Yoruba chants
[Music]
yoruba comes from Nigeria and me and
Wednesday we shipped to Cuba their
culture remained Cuban our mother took
us to yoga choir for the first time we
were 15 and we fell in love with their
songs and we are staged every night
singing those songs we're honored to be
part of this culture it's almost like we
are sponges so we take everything in and
it mixes up inside our bellies and then
it comes back and it sounds like even
it's really weird truly is like that
[Music]
this is our song deathless from our
second album ash normally I come to the
studio with the piano and the melody and
the lyrics but this time it started with
the beat and with the bass
it's heavy and dark
now meet and Richard Russell our
producer both created this object
[Music]
deathless is a really important song in
our album we wanted people to understand
the power they have
when I was 16 I got stopped in the
subway by policeman and they were like
do you smoke and I said no and you like
to use drugs and I said no do you drink
and I said no and then there were lay
are you effing kidding me
and really really close to my face I
didn't understand obviously he was a
racist and then she made me take out my
socks and my shoes he took my bag and
threw everything on the floor like that
but when he saw I had a huge book I was
reading Anna Karenina he froze gave me
my empty bag back and left and then I
forgot about it but when our producer
Richard Russell asked us to run a write
a song about it I said I can't my story
is like nothing and now he said
something incredible I said that it's
wrong and it was already enough and she
should talk about it so after having
this bee in my ears I started writing
the lyrics on exactly what this
policeman said to me
[Music]
what's here
we realized that actually what we wanted
to do was an anthem for everybody to
feel deathless to feel immortal for
three minutes for everybody to feel like
one and to fill their own power and we
created that
[Music]
that's this but usually what we do is we
loop our own voices over and over and
over again because it's an anthem we
need other voices so we call this
amazing choir and we all sang
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
even the sound guy even Richard Russell
our producer our mother was that the old
sang weird efforts together and it was
an incredible experience so once we had
the beat and actually the melody and the
lyrics they went back to the studio and
you are do dramas that's or that they
were like we grew up with our father
being one of the stars of a Latin jazz
world a master of the percussion when
our father died were left that same you
feel like walking let's try to make them
when she played the Cajon for the first
time there's something that happened and
we all felt it every sight this is it
it was not just the rhythm it was lived
our fathers genes were in her it was
almost like you had played for years
already
I play the Cajon or the better come on
it's what we use for Yoruba traditional
ceremony in Cuba really but this made
out of skin my master me killed by
ambrósio he does it with wood so he made
this for me I really like to mix
electronic sounds and some wood and so I
just find that rhythm
it could be one day a hip-hop beat that
she actually deconstruct oh it could be
a pop beat but also can be a traditional
pattern from the Yoruba culture we found
a bass sound when we combine voices
traditional drums and wood and
electronics and this is when it all
clicks
[Music]
there's some songs that are really hard
to do and there's some songs and you
don't know why it's almost magical
everything fits and that's what that's
always our whole love for music it's
mixing we are proud to mix everything
for it to still feel that it comes from
your heart music has a power that has no
boundaries
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
blues is a feeling and it is in
experience blues is about something that
happens in my life my name is Beverly
Watkins I was born here in Atlanta
Georgia in 1939 Beverly Watkins was a
pioneer for women it lose when I was
playing back in the sixties there wasn't
no female guitar players not in Georgia
they said I play like a man but they're
using the wrong terminology the main
thing is because I play so good after
high school
Beverly began touring with the band
piano red and the meter toads shortly
thereafter she was opening for some of
the biggest acts in music we opened up
for James Brown VB teen Otis Redding
I played over two or three thousand
shows back in those days the artists
took time and hope each other
her hard classic blues style has evolved
over the last 60 years touring with
different bands and eventually going
solo
I never stopped when they said I should
I didn't pay him no mind I kept going
yes it has gotten hard out there you
know I clean houses I worked at car
washes I clean offices but I never
stopped playing my music
and she has no plans on stopping anytime
soon
well into her 70s she still puts on a
show for the crowd
it is keeping me living keeping me going
come on look good and have a good time
and get up there and do my thing there's
like a strong violent culture in Africa
as a whole being able to see the violent
culture in all of these different ways
it just resonated with me because I am
african-american and I know that my
African research from somewhere it just
opened up my whole mind to the idea of
violin and like what you can do with it
[Music]
my name is Sudan archives and I am a
finger song writer producer and
violinist from Cincinnati Ohio my songs
are all about textures this is one idea
with all of these ways to get different
sounds my songs usually start with my
violin and then once I find like a idea
on the violin I usually have like my
Loop Station with me I'm able to just
add more layers and more layers or more
layers to that I can pitch the octave
down I can just make a sound like an
accordion or wind instrument being able
to have technology it's probably why I'm
able to like be a solo artist because I
wouldn't be able to do all these things
at once this is my song not for sale off
my EP sings this is Madison
this is my kitchen this is a start song
I usually start with violin the whole
format of not for sale is just this
simple violin riff the style of the
plucking came from like my fiddle
background all the other melodic parks
are basically variations of that riff my
parents raised us and like this strict
church environment my biological dad as
a preacher like behind a tree Bible
first isn't right pages about of my
stepdad he was a music producer he
really wanted me to pursue music he just
really pushed like the creative side of
me baroque violin shop is a store in
Cincinnati
[Music]
I first got into violin because the
owner a baroque violin shop came to my
school and played the cello played the
violin and had this like really cool
story with it but also like using loop
stations and effect pedals that was when
I was like okay I need to get a violin
[Music]
I'd still be they condone as a waitress
either something or an insult at school
maybe if I didn't keep playing violin
and my keep experimenting but the thing
was it wasn't that I played by LAN it
looks like seeing you and seeing these
different kinds of violin players
because not just Orchestra settings like
see ya man my thoughts really it's music
yeah it's not we really couldn't even
afford violin lessons my mom suggested
that I play with the choir at my church
there was no other like violinist up
there so then I eventually developed a
sense of ear when someone just says
anything I'm able to like just play the
same thing there's kind of only three
parts to the song which is violin bass
and drums
whatever riff I'm playing one of those
notes is going to be the bass line
all the other parts of the song that
aside from violin are just kind of like
simple variations to just kind of
amplify it definitely like the drums
like if I want to be like doing flat and
the bass on the verse it was an electric
bass but on the pre hood it changes into
this sub electronic bass I create all of
those ideas with the violin and then I
just kind of like follow the lead of the
violin with other electronic instruments
in the computer Lord we thank you for
this food that we're about to receive
for the nourishment of our bodies in
Christ's name we pray amen amen
I never really liked my name Brittany
and I was like mama I really like my
name she was like what about Sudan so I
started going by Sudan
actually my mom everyone just calls me
Sudan one day I just decided to just
check out the music in Sudan and I found
all of this really cool music and
there's like a strong violent culture in
Sudan specifically but also in Africa as
a whole
I changed it to Sudan archives because
of this like ethnomusicologist she
specifically like studies like West
Africans fiddling and they're playing
all these crazy like in harmonics and
all the stuff was just one string there
was like never really any other black
people playing violins so when I saw
like people in Africa planet that looked
like me that makes me feel really good
for some reason maybe I'm not an outcast
[Music]
once I changed my name to Sudan archives
it just kind of started to click and it
kind of made me want to keep practicing
violin because there's so many different
ways you can play it
[Music]
you shouldn't think about it so hard
it's just self-expression I was like hey
there's no excuse to not keep going
you can literally teach yourself or make
up your own style
[Music]
the lyrics are kind of self-explanatory
but I was just feeling a little you know
used at the time it was like mainly just
about my close relationships but then
it's like a bigger picture to it the
whole moral of it is just like knowing
your self-worth this is my this is my
kitchen - this is my time don't waste it
up this is my land not for sale
you can't buy me you can't sell me
I can't trade me can't be me so stop the
word not came from a sign I saw in Ghana
it was like a big piece of land I was
like what is that sign and they were
like oh it's just so unbought the line'
and they just saying it's not for sale
so I was like oh that's that's let's
live it just like an ode to my first
trip to Africa and that was my first
plane ride off the country as well so
now I have that memory forever this is
my time don't we
[Music]
a lot of people say like when they see
me on stage by myself trigging
everything multitasking doing it all is
something inspiring to them I hope that
it can inspire people to do that in
their own way whatever they're doing I
want to create new ideas with my music
[Music]